I mean yesterday my mom texted me I
guess Brian Cranston was just on Kelly
Clarkson this week like talking about
the big like death scene with me and
they're sending it to me I'm like all
right cool yeah yeah so really yeah do
you so do you still talk to Aaron and
Brian yeah I just saw Aaron at a karaoke
party I love Aaron Thomas he's such a
nice guy he was nervous about karaokeing
oh God and then he ended up doing it
really would be great he was great yeah
but what was that experience I mean you
were on how many episodes I don't know
not many not many I was in the second
season maybe like Eight Episodes I don't
know uh well then that's a lot one
episode The Following season
and how many episodes did you think you
were going to be on when you first got
the part like five I ended up being in
it more than I thought
and was it something that you it was
already hit by this point it wasn't a
hit it wasn't a hit at this point it
wasn't even like on the radar yet when I
took the gig it was only one season
seven episode show because of the
writer's strike so it was a big down and
down time in the industry it was all
slow
um I really liked the part and I wanted
to get it and my agent at the time he
was really good and really smart his
name was David Letterman I was at with a
d Letterman with a D I was at Innovative
artist I had another offer for something
else that was more of like what I was
doing what I was doing and he was like
let's hang on and let's see what happens
with breaking bad because no one knows
about the show yet but it's but it's
really good and I think you could be
really cool in this role so we held we
waited until I until that happened and
you were so happy you got that [__] yeah
because it was more like it was like you
know I I just felt like it was more in
my like real house yeah yeah yeah
because before that I was just doing a
lot of like goofy ditzy kind of Comedy
roles which are fun too but you know it
was Vince on set yeah Vince was on set
or he was like you know what was really
cool about him and those kind of show
Runners Melissa Rosenberg is similar
very detail-oriented and I think that is
like the key I think when you have
someone with such a true Clear Vision
that's why you get some magic
yeah when you say
detailed like we're talking yeah was
Vince directing that episode no he
directed El Camino right um but that
episode or a few the episodes that you
did he didn't direct but he was there
and he's sort of like almost like
Spielberg Tove Hooper and Poltergeist
where top Hooper was directing it but
did Spielberg direct it well it's just
kind of the thing like for just for one
stupid example like the character is
wearing a belt they take pictures of
both belts and they goes to Vince Vince
is going to choose the you know what I
mean yes yes all little things like
everything mattered to him which I think
is very cool
um and Melissa Rosenberg has a similar
style and it doesn't that doesn't always
happen with showrunners right it's like
a free for all